make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in light of the aftermath of
everything going on with CW right and
and I'm a little late to this party
right but in everything with the
aftermath of CW's crisis on Infinite
Earths and the current state of the DC
film universe and all I kind of stuff I
figured we'd make a video on how to
reboot everything with regards to Warner
Brothers the TV shows the movies the
whole nine yards and and I think the
reason why is because you know
everything that happened with CW's
crisis on Infinite Earths really
presents the opportunity right the the
antimatter is essentially just on the
backburner now right like he's just
shrunk anybody and he's in the
Microverse and that's it but like
there's a possibility for him to return
somewhere along the line that's entirely
possible there well you also have is
like a merged universe right you have
like Earth Prime now where you have like
all the different heroes across the
entire CW landscape that are all
seemingly on a singular world now
protecting their world and it's really
gonna be like kind of a combined thing
going forward right so you're not gonna
watch Supergirl show on CW and never see
the flash unless like they cross over
into that universe for some event that's
going on or something like that you know
you essentially have a great big shared
universe but it seemingly only seems to
involve the CW side at least that
appeared to be the case until Azra
Miller met Grant Gustin and then it's
like okay so like they're all part of a
multiverse now right like the CW side
all converged into a singular earth but
then you also have you know the the DC
film universe which is his own universe
right it's separate from everything else
and we all kind of knew that right we
all kind of had you know even if DC had
necessarily confirmed it in so far as
saying here's where things stand here's
this map of the multiverse and here's
the universal justice league and here's
the universe with flash and with
Supergirl and with like lightning and
all these different things you know even
if we weren't really told that we still
kind of knew that was what was going on
right so my question is if with
everything going on right now does it
warrant you know any kind of a reboot
and if it does how do you do that right
like where do you start because it's
almost like shooting b-roll on a camera
right like you need your hero footage
your hero footage of the footage that
you use but you match everything else -
right like that's that's kind of how
that works
all the other color graded footage is
designed to match that right so because
of that we kind of have to start with
that that's central point what's the
focal point what's the point by which we
basically originate everything and we do
it with CW right the money is
technically in the film universe and I
know this seems backwards to kind of go
with a TV side and then work your way to
the movies but bear with me here because
I think it'll all make sense right so
what does CW did is it introduced the
anti-monitor one of the most notable
villains in the history of DC Comics
notable for the crisis on Infinite
Earths story in 1985 bye-bye Marv
Wolfman and George Perez that's the
single biggest thing that the
anti-monitor is known for everything
else is relative on how familiar you are
with with DC Comics if you're an avid
reader of DC Comics and a fan of Green
Lantern
you know the anti-monitor from like the
Sinestro Corps war different things like
that but if you never read Green Lantern
you don't know what Sinestro Corps war
is you'd have no clue that the
anti-monitor was involved in that I'd
bet all the money in my pockets - all
the money in your pockets that if I
walked up to somebody and said have you
ever heard of the anti-monitor from DC
Comics they would at the very least make
some loose connection between the
anti-monitor and crisis on Infinite
Earths or reference crisis on Infinite
Earths in in some form or fashion the
story is just so notable and so because
of that the anti-monitor exists now the
antimatter is on the back burner I say
keep him there for a little while and
then bring him back at the end of things
now what's the end of things and how do
we go from here okay at this point we
kind of used the the CW as the main
focal point right we say essentially
everything is going to revolve around
the CW fail at CW TV show universe right
it's not the highest of budget but it's
solid right the the the stories and the
cohesiveness and all that kind of stuff
especially now feels a lot more solid
than the DC film universe does and the
reason is this you when you look at the
film Man of Steel right I wouldn't say
that it feels too hopeless and I
wouldn't say it's the worst Superman
movie that was ever made but I will
certainly say that Superman in that
movie did not feel like Superman
Superman by the time he gets onto the
scene even if you want to show his
origin right you want to show Clark Kent
growing up you want to give us some know
some instances which were actually
really cool where Jonathan Kent is
giving his son morally questionable
advice about revealing his identity to
the world or even saving people because
the world's not not ready for the kind
of power that he has and they needs to
keep that hidden from the world even if
it means letting people die that's cool
that's so that's a really awesome
philosophical viewpoint and I love
having debates like that and if I met
any one of you guys we could talk about
that you know at a bar for hours on end
but regardless of what direction you
decide to take the origin in by the time
Clark Kent makes the decision to become
Superman it's no longer the time for I'm
not sure or I'm not certain or is
humanity really worth saving he's made
that choice humanity's worth saving
humanity are flawed and and we are
overly emotional and we are illogical
and we do stupid things and we don't
make sense but we are capable of an
credible things and Superman has to be
the guy that can basically lead us there
more so than that if any other
superheroes exist you know at the time
the Superman rises to is to his level of
notoriety but may in turn look to
Superman as the model in which they want
to follow they look at that and say okay
so I've kind of been flying by the seat
of my pants all this time but like that
guy over of a Trappist man he's got to
figure it out right I mean look at the
confidence right look at the way he's
stand look at how his cape moves
the guy's not scared to wear underwear
on his pants this guy is legit
but nonetheless you know it's it's one
of these these these cool things where
Superman has to be the character by
which all other heroes would want to
model themselves after right they want
to be like him they want to be the good
guy the guy that seems to always make
the right choice and if he's unsure
about the decision that he's making he's
not telling anybody right like that's
the kind of guy that we walk by that's
the kind of hero that we want when you
look at Wonder Woman one of them was
solid right not a whole lot to say there
it was a fantastic movie it was exactly
what I wanted Wonder Woman to be we
don't have a Batman film yet Aquaman
didn't really feel like Aquaman right I
didn't I didn't look at that movie and
see like a guy who is basic one part
surface dweller one part Atlantean and
who's trying to strike a balance between
these two opposing forces which are
seemingly always on the brink of going
to war with each other now this was an
origin film and it was really just the
new 52 origin by Geoff Johns when
Aquaman first picked up so I guess that
makes sense if you're focusing on an
origin but at the end of the day it
still didn't feel like Aquaman right
like I don't I never really expected to
go into an Aquaman movie and then at
some point along the line feel like they
were gonna turn a corner and then
suddenly be in Bayfront Park in Miami at
the Ultra Music Festival right like I
wasn't really expecting that and it
doesn't really seem kind of Aquaman
esque in that regard I expected a guy
who's a little hottie but also has a
little bit of a gentler side to him a
little bit of a little bit of humbleness
to him not a whole lot but a guy who's
kind of like if you're gonna come and
address me you speak to me like I'm a
king right like not some guy who's
getting drunk you know on some little
shore area some small little village
town didn't have anything to do with the
world right like not really what I was
expecting there it wasn't terrible it
just didn't quite feel like Aquaman to
me Shazam was fantastic Shazam was an
answer to the question what would you do
if you were like 15 years old and you
got the powers of Superman well I mean
you would do exactly what he did you'd
have like the most fun ever quite like
you'd be awesome but the story was
fantastic dr. Saban about Mark Strong he
was legit one of the best films that
I've seen in comic book movies in a long
time to be honest he didn't really
let's formulate some of the villas that
you see in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I didn't feel like you was some of the
guys some of you guys may feel like you
was I didn't really feel like he was
well I feel like he was pretty solid and
when I look at the blackout a movie that
was not really out yet but looking at
the characters we're supposed to
beginning right like dr. fate and and
Hawkgirl and Hawkman and Isis and atom
smasher and these various guys I felt
you know it looks like it's gonna be
cool
and then I look at Justice League and
Justice League kind of it just feels
like it all just sort of fell on its
face right it just feels lackluster it
doesn't it doesn't really feel
significant right it's just kind of like
it's just a hodgepodge of things going
on and it doesn't really seem to be any
order or any structure it's just it
seems about as bad as a comic book movie
could get right you know and at least in
this day and age it's not Howard the
Duck bad but it ain't that far off and
I'm pretty sure most everybody agreed
because of how poorly it was rated right
so I wouldn't when it comes to these
it's kind of like okay you know there's
there's got to be ample room to
basically we work everything and so what
I would do is I would say if the
entirety of the DC Multiverse
in in both the film and the TV universe
was not wiped out right it basically
only really pertained to the TV side and
what it means is there's all these other
universes that are out there with
regards to these various DC heroes that
we know and who knows how they may have
turned out at the same time we've got
the anti-monitor on the backburner and
what DC needs and what they seem to have
seem to not really have in their film
universe is a-- is a direction right the
idea that like all of this is going in
this direction and i hate to make the
comparison with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it's what they did so well
right like it's really since like yummy
with the first movie with with with Iron
Man it was okay this is going in the
direction of Avengers cool I'm really
excited for Avengers but then as the
movie started to grow and as more and
more Easter eggs were dropped in it's
like no no this is not going in the
direction of the Avengers this is going
in the direction of infinity war that
was the big that was the big conflict
that was the big battle that was very it
was all leading to and then once that
was done we're gonna start the process
all over again but with different
characters and so the DC film universe
doesn't feel like it has that right like
I don't really look at the movies and
say okay this is all leading towards
this great big huge thing it may have
felt like that at one point but at this
point it really kind of feels like the
movies are disheveled and they're
they're they're disconnected and they're
kind of all over the place of sort of
jumbled what they need is cohesiveness
they need a scenario whereby they say
everything going on here this is all
going to plan right this is all the way
that we wanted us go is how everything
is unfolding and now we're gonna shift
directions right so the question
if we were gonna do that and we were
going to reboot the DC film universe how
do we do it right we can't really do
crisis on Infinite Earths because we saw
Ezra Miller appear at the end of the
flash with Grant Gustin so we know that
like his universe is still intact it was
not destroyed by the anti-monitor so
it's like okay that's still there so
that options off the table and and
crisis on Infinite Earths has already
been done in CW so we can't bring the
anti-monitor back for a crisis that
seems to affect the other half of the
multiverse and then somehow send the
anti-monitor away it would feel cheap
but it would feel cheap and it would
feel like a like a cop-out then my
thoughts started going to what about
like Infinite Crisis or Final Crisis
right like borrow the name continue the
trend but what if we wanted to use that
later on down the line and so then I
started thinking okay well let's think
let's think outside of the box right
let's move away from the idea of a
crisis because that's already been done
and let's do something else instead and
then it dawned on me in reality if it
were up to me and and one of others came
to me and said how would you do this I
would earth to that I would basically
have a scenario where Darkseid just
shows up on that on that earth and it's
just like he's here now and he just
likes like wipes all the superheroes out
just done right it's the aftermath of
the Justice League and it's this thing
that like if you want someone right you
got to do it yourself right step and
we'll fail the heroes were a lot more
capable than Dark Sun initially expected
so he's like okay fine I'll just do it
myself he shows up there and like
there's no there's there's no real hope
in this movie right there's no like okay
like somebody's gonna happen they're
gonna stand a chance and they're all
gonna come out on top and the day's
gonna be saved yeah yeah you know no no
no no like there this is it right this
is it for this universe they're done
when the movie ends all the superheroes
are taken out all the superheroes are
crushed the superheroes are destroyed
but it has to be done in a way where you
don't walk out feeling like man the
world is bleak and it sucks this is just
depressing as hell right you don't want
to walk out feeling like Cthulhu is
risen you want to walk out feeling like
okay so like that was pretty cool and
you want to know what's gonna happen
next right like okay I want to know what
comes next
out of this right like what's the next
big thing to take place and so that's
that's literally I would do I would I
would have dark so I just show up on
that earth gal gadot Wonder Woman Henry
Cavill Superman whoever it isn't as a
plain Batman
the the the sparkly glitter Twilight guy
from the old like Jason Momoa as Aquaman
Zachary Levi Susanne the you know Dwayne
the rock Johnson's Black Adam like I
would just boom like they're all just
taken out right like they're all just
eliminated by Darkseid just like that
right because what it does is it gives
us this full scale of just how capable
Darkseid
is right like Superman could take on the
entire Justice League by himself and
that was cool and black Adams gonna be
able to taking on all these characters
by himself and that's cool and all these
characters took on dark side and got
rekt and not even by a little bit like
by up pretty big margin like it was just
it was the ass whippin of a lifetime
right like the Justice League's on the
ropes the entire time and then they're
just taken out and that's basically it
movie ends cut to the next universe and
the next universe we get all the heroes
that were familiar with Batman is done
the way the Batman supposed to be
Superman is done the way he's supposed
to be Wonder Woman has done the way the
Wonder Woman was already done because it
was fantastic Aquaman has done the way
Aquaman should be done
Shazam is is done the exact same way
that is supposed to be done Black Adam
the exact same thing right like that's
to me that the movie turns out to be
good but nonetheless it's one of these
things were like they basically fix the
mistakes they made this time around they
kind of go back to the drawing board and
say okay how do we do it right this time
but the other big thing that comes out
of this is it gives us a direction it
gives us the villain what it basically
says is Darkseid's traveling around the
multiverse conquering earths turning its
entire inhabitants into parademons he's
building an army for something what the
hell is he building this army fort
where'd you end up finding out because
literally anti-monitor is doing the
exact same thing in the Microverse
whatever it is he happens to be building
an army as well maybe Darkseid tried to
invade the Microverse with the
anti-monitor it's maybe Darkseid is
aware of the anti-monitor maybe he saw
the events of crisis on Infinite Earths
taking place and saying well it's only a
matter of time before he comes to me
whatever the case is Darkseid is
amassing an army and so is the
anti-monitor and eventually they're
gonna go to war with each other and
maybe you have all the heroes who side
with Darkseid you have all the villains
who side with the anti-monitor
the they're signing with Darkseid is a
loose agreement right like you know
don't kill us and like will side with
you but like the instant you turn on us
we're all gonna try to kill you in turn
right like it's one of these things
worse like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend like that's that's kind of how I
would play it but you it basically gives
us like the great big huge grandiose
conflict at the end which is dark side
versus the anti-monitor
something akin to dark side war from
from the new 52 doesn't have to be
exactly like that but more or less
brings us that same thing by breezes
that same concept the whole conflict
ends and then whatever happens after
that happens after that it depends on
you know who's who's you know who's
organizing this and structuring all this
but that's kind of my vision now pin
mine this is this is napkin right Liz
this is me in a cafe drinking a glass of
water and just jotting stuff down on a
napkin
like that with more planning and more
structure it could probably be a whole
lot better right because it's already a
ton of potholes in this I imagine you
know but it's kind of off top my head
here's how I would do this right so
again it's one of these things where you
kinda have to plan it out you have to
structure it you have to make sure the
logistics work but the big takeaway from
all this the B does the big
end-all-be-all of all this is that what
we would get is we would basically get
the cast of The CW universe crossing
over with the cast of the film universe
in the films right like we would get
that we would get Grant Gustin in like
some flash movie and then we would get
you know Supergirl in some Superman
movie and then we would see like
Superman up here in the Supergirl TV
show even if only for a moment because
the the TV side doesn't have the same
budget as the movie side but essentially
you would see these characters cross
over and you would know that like even
if they're not sharing the same universe
they're sharing the same multiverse and
like they're doing whatever and things
are going on whatever the case happens
to be but it would kind of bring
everything together it would organize
and structure at all and I think would
provide some much-needed cohesiveness to
the DC film universe but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section I'm kind of curious if you guys
are new here to come as explained mix
you guys to the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a light
and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
atención experience
[Music]
[Music]